Let's move on to drawing lines.
You can follow along by loading
up 1.3.03 demo drawing lines.
So first, let's get start up
as usual by declaring and
initializing a ShapeRenderer.
Also, we gotta remember to
clean up after ourselves and
get rid of anything we're not using.
Also note,
instead of using ApplicationListener,
we're using ApplicationAdapter here.
ApplicationAdapter is just a convenience
implementation of ApplicationListener.
It stubs out all of the required
methods with implementations that
don't do anything.
So all we've got here is actually
create, dispose, and render.
All right, as always, all
the interesting stuff happens in render.
So first, we clear the screen.
We actually clear the screen and then,
we start a new shapeRenderer batch.
This time, using the Line ShapeType.
All right, now we're going to draw
a line from 0, 0 to 100, 100.
Let's give it a try.
Well, that didn't go according to plan.
There's nothing on the screen and
we actually got an error down here.
Let's see.
Illegal state exception.
Call end before beginning
a new shape batch.
Oh, right.
So all we did here was
start the batch and
then draw a line but
didn't end the batch.
Then the next time render got called
it tried to begin a batch but
shape render was already in the middle
of a batch so we got a crash.
All right, let's try this again.
Awesome.
We're in business.
Let's try something more interesting.
Let's try drawing a line of a different
color, by using shapeRenderer.setColor,
and then using one of
the pre-defined color constants.
Then we'll draw another line
slightly offset from the first one.
Hm, whoops.
Well we got our magenta line, but
the first line we drew
also ended up magenta.
The way colors work with shapeRenderer
is it will assume you want white
until you tell it about
some other color.
However, if you tell it
about some other color,
it will retroactively assume everything
you wanted you draw before that,
you wanted to draw that color as well.
let's try this setup.
Hey, there we go,
that's what we were looking for.
We can also set colors
using our RGBA values.
Now before we draw this line,
what color is this?
So it's fully opaque because
alpha's one, so that's good.
All right there's no red and there's
no blue, so the line must be green.
Let's run it and see.
Our predictions were correct..
We can even do fancy things like drawing
lines with gradients by specifying
the color at start of a line and
the color at the end.
And there we go.
We got a nice fade from blue to red.
One more useful thing for drawing lines.
If we wanted to draw a whole
series of line segments,
it would get really tiresome
to draw each one individually.
So we also have polyline.
Polyline takes an array of floats,
where the floats at the even positions
are the x coordinates, and the floats at
the odd positions are the y coordinates.
If we give this one a try,
we see this crazy path with a bunch
of connected line segments.